cela a commencé comme des vacances ou
désireux d'échapper à un avenir radieux dans les
Grandes Plaines
Arthur howitzer jr.  a transformé la
série de chroniques de récits de voyage en
dépêche française un rapport hebdomadaire factuel
sur les sujets de la politique mondiale les
arts hauts et bas et diverses histoires d'
intérêt humain vous ne pensez pas que c'est
presque pour voir Jésus à lui non je ne les
gens décents  censé être charmant, il a
réuni une équipe des meilleurs
journalistes patriotes de son temps Berenson Sazerac
kremens Roebuck les écrit pour son
peuple, essayez simplement de donner l'impression que
vous l'avez écrit de cette façon exprès que nous prenons
comme sujet de la conférence de ce soir, m.
Moses Rosenthal certainement la voix autiste la plus bruyante
de sa génération tapageuse
simone nu cellblock J hobby room je
veux l'acheter c'est pas à vendre oui
c'est oh ouais hier oui pour ça oui
en bref la photo a fait sensation
les enfants ont fait ça en a
effacé mille  ans d'
autorité républicaine en moins de
quinze jours qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent la liberté
point
final je suis nu mrs.  Crimmins je peux les voir
lieutenant miss caffee est le grand
exemple du moule de la cuisine connue sous le nom de
cuisine policière les arômes de la cuisine
dégagent une odeur qui devait être mortellement
brisée comme vous le savez maintenant nous avons
kidnappé votre fils
[Musique]
[Musique  ]
un message du contremaître une heure pour
presser t'es viré
ne pleure pas dans mon bureau
[Applaudissements]
toi